what up y'all I'm in beautiful
Chinatown
Las Vegas
today because I'm about to get a tattoo
this time it's not for a joke it's not
the lift laugh love one this one is
gonna be super heartfelt it's gonna be
super CUNY and it's something I've
actually been scheduling for eight
months like uh every single time that I
try to get a tattoo booking and if you
guys have gotten tattoos you know when
you get a good artist it'll be like
three months down the line but as soon
as it gets close I got life that keeps
popping up and I finally got some time
I'm back at home and I'm gonna get it
done at skin design tattoo
in the world famous Chinatown Las Vegas
so I do got one problem the thing with
tattoos is you're stuck there for a long
time so I gotta map out my food and I
still gotta get my steps in so I do see
a lee sandwich which is absolutely
delicious and it's calling my name it's
a Vietnamese coffee a nice little
sandwich
and that should be able to hold me over
um so I'm also looking for lunch or
maybe even dinner
and good thing I came across Hawaiian
style poke I look so good got four stars
276 reviews
that'll help out
the tattoo session if I take a break
and then I can just walk down get my
steps and at the same time get something
kind of clean and that's what's kind of
helpful about the whole Chinatown area
like not to mention that it's pretty on
the nose so if you're ever on Spring
Mountain you know you know you're in
Spring Mountain
but you got a ton of good food here
chinese vietnamese Japanese
Hawaiians doing a rap song Filipino Thai
all of that you know
oh so bad
that was so bad sorry I'm a dad now
oh my goodness
I love pastries dude Jesus oh oh my God
all right I gotta get the cleanest thing
on the menu
so looking at that menu I'm thinking the
grilled chicken
um light on the Mayo oh but look at that
egg though Jesus Christ oh
hey if I gotta be a good boy
so I could stay sexy but look Oh my
Jesus dude what the [__] man
oh boy oh boy
bro life
does not get any
better than this
a bun Mei listen to this rapper bro this
is ASMR right here fresh forget got
chicken got some pickled veggies
oh a soft freshly break break baked
bread too
this coffee
before tattoo genius
out of the back
truck too so I'm at my tailgate right
here see
he's hanging out in the parking lot
this is good
um
all right y'all so I'm here with Orlando
he's uh the tattoo artist and this is
what we're gonna get so this is this
space in my arm this bicep and I've been
wanting to get this tattoo for a long
time and it's a picture of taika you
guys know how much I love taika
obviously and there's this picture of
him but I've always liked where he dives
into the pool and he has like these
little like crab goggles so for the
tattoo you think we can get them like a
little bit more zoomed in yeah for sure
I think that's probably the best
honestly yeah especially to kind of get
the details the details of the goggles
the goggles yeah yeah I like that yes I
love his face this is one of the first
times he learned how to swim and then
you guys know his favorite phrase which
is Boom Shakalaka DD but I want the
juxtaposition of it being gangster as
[__] so here's some samples of like Old
English or scripted but yeah I wanted to
have that
wrap around his face let's say boom
shakalaka
and then DD at the bottom and then we
have his cute little face and I'll
remember that forever
so we'll come back in like about 45
minutes to an hour like an hour okay I
can get some food or get something okay
sounds good oh yeah dude what a blessing
in disguise you guys remember how I was
saying I'm worried oh my gosh I'm gonna
be sitting here all day how am I gonna
get my steps in well Orlando needed
about an hour to draw so I was like oh
[__] that's what I didn't account for
let's get to Stepping so I walked all
the way down to the wind on a foot which
is kind of cool because I never got to
experience Vegas from like all the back
freeways back Alleyways I actually
crossed the freeway like a homeless man
too because the way that maps map it
when you don't have it on walking mode
it's going to take you the way it drives
and I forgot about that so I'm like
walking and uh oh I can't get here but I
need to cut across and that's the
shortest way is to just cross the
freeway so I ended up crossing over the
freeway and look how many steps I got
000. so I only needed to get 11 000
today and since I knew I was gonna have
a tattoo appointment this morning I
walked extra already so I already got in
like five six thousand but now I got a
13 000 just got the text that he's ready
for me so about to go in and get taika
on my arm so this is that just the
outline okay yeah and so what I'm
thinking is like so you know that
beveled look that we had yeah so I think
kind of maybe like the bevel and then we
faded into this negative oh yeah that's
it I like the fade yeah yeah
sick
that's dope yeah it's gonna be hard and
that way we can go a lot bigger with the
portrait yeah yeah so this will be faded
too soon we'll cover his forehead
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why
you're an artist dude you could think of
things I can't even think of
that looks dope yeah I think it's gonna
be hard hell yeah so originally I was
gonna have the orientation like this but
we realized we can't fit as much of the
face in the lettering so we're gonna
bring it down like that and that's what
it's gonna look like
all right let's do it sweets let me just
get the stencil ready we'll get jamming
okay all right one step closer
we got the stencil on
so that's what it looks like
let me zoom in a little bit
so that's what it looks like right there
it's nice and centered boom shaka Locka
DD and of course the other stupid tattoo
I got but it fits good and I'm glad we
have this formation so you can see his
face a little bit more
yeah that's good but cool
attack is gonna be so happy
[Music]
so Orlando yeah what got you into
tattooing
um so I started tattooing when I was
like 15. whoa yeah and um how old are
you now I'm 27. damn for 12 years yeah
about 12 years yes sir wow and uh yeah
just being around it you know my cousins
and my brothers all getting tatted and
it was just kind of part of the culture
so
yeah you just like the
like the art the art yeah so I got into
graffiti first yeah and then from there
um I did my first tattoo when I was 15.
oh my God that was my sister's brother
oh no my sisters
my sister's boyfriend my sister's
boyfriend at the time was a tattooer
um was that scary not really I think I
was just so pumped and it was on my
brother so I wasn't too nervous
did you pack this on like
like pig skin or like fake skin or any
of that stuff it was only my homie
homie homies yeah [__] damn so I just
went straight for it
so I have a buddy when he first got into
tattooing and he says when you give a
tattoo the first time yeah the
adrenaline is so crazy because you're
literally like doing surgery with art
essentially right so using the
adrenaline rush you got from tattooing
someone was way more than getting a
tattoo did you feel that way or not
um I don't remember it was so long ago
yeah I just remember being so excited
because I had been interested in the
idea since I was maybe like 10 11 years
old yeah yeah so when were you able to
start like charging and making money
from it
probably after my apprenticeship so
maybe like 19 20 years old
because when I was when I was a younger
tattooing I knew like
where my work was at yeah it was more so
just doing it for fun yeah so I wasn't
really charging people
what made you go like okay I need to
like take this serious and get a
printing ship once I graduated high
school oh yeah once I graduated high
school
um I knew I didn't want to go to college
or nothing so I knew tattooing is what I
wanted to do so to just pursued it like
yeah just went straight for it yeah
that's dope man I always love stories
like that yes people that know what they
want they just go 100 yeah I had to go
hard and
um
that was kind of like a deal I had with
my mom you know she was like if I
graduated high school then I could do
whatever yeah then I could uh
go tattoo you know yeah yeah that's dope
because I I didn't even want to finish
school I was like I was gonna attend
just drop out right now right but she
was like yeah you can only tattoo if you
finish high school did you know how much
money a tattoo artists make no not at
the time and honestly I didn't oh right
right you know yeah that's true you
don't know until you get into the
business of it sure yeah
and like that it wasn't even where my
head was at when I first started you
know it was just the love of the article
yeah just yeah tattooing is just
different you know yeah
bro are you [__] kidding me so you
know how I told you guys I had it all
planned out I know what I'm gonna eat
for lunch now I'm gonna walk there get
even more steps in
so now it is four o'clock time to get a
little break in and look it is closed
why are you closing at 4 P.M dude
so now I gotta go Plan B
or is this the Universe telling me I
should eat something delicious and
disgusting I'm just candy I can't I
actually uh have a competition real soon
so I gotta make weight
so let's see what the next closest one
there's another one oh
I'm gonna have to go to a competitor
this one's only a quarter mile away
so sorry Hawaiian style Pokey I wanted
to go to you guys but you guys close so
I have to go to Pokemon now see
get direction oh four minute walk that's
close
let's go
so I'm actually very excited they call
Vegas the ninth Island right there's so
many Hawaiians here that it's the
honorary Island to the island of Hawaii
and since I've been out here I have not
tried Hawaiian Pokemons I've been super
traumatized by all the like fast food
Subway style poke place in California
that I almost refused poke it unless I'm
in Hawaii but since this is the ninth
Island I'm like I gotta give it a shot
and that and both of the Poke spots I
looked at had four stars so
must be good there it is
Pokeman
still in the same like Chinese style
building
so relatively still in the heart
of Chinatown this was only like a three
minute walk I think of the tattoo shop
so that's really close let's see what
they got they got Sushi burritos
that's crazy what
back at the shop
this is what it looks like
smells pretty good looks pretty good
all right so now for the Moment of Truth
get some rice
get some of the tuna oops hmm
actually very good
still the same my Subway style it's not
like Hawaii where everything's pre-made
and it's sitting there
um everything was just raw ingredients
and they mix it but the flavoring is on
point it's very very good
so definitely get at least one thumbs up
oh look how cute this picture looks
that's cute
all right I want to show you guys some
progress
so we pretty much have the bottom
lettering done not only getting to the
face part right here
and then the meat and potatoes of the
whole thing but it's turning out pretty
good
I was showing Geo
uh pictures of the tattoo while it's
while I was getting it and then she saw
that the stencil went over a lift Laugh
Love she's like you better not cover it
because remember I lost the the get lean
Challenge and I don't know don't worry I
want I want to keep it for memories
um
but she was like yeah she thought I
would get it covered up and I'm keeping
it forever
all right here's the update on the
tattoo
halfway through
the face got the goggles about to do
the top of the crabs and then we got the
lettering and then we're done
what is your uh
what is your favorite part about
tattooing and then what is like
um one of the toughest things about
tattooing that maybe regular people
don't know
so we'll start with the favorite part
yeah I think my favorite part of
tattooing is like uh just getting to
meet new people and have an impact on
people yeah also you know getting to
provide for my family doing what I love
yeah yeah that shit's always dope yeah
um [__] the hardest part of tattooing
or like what's the part about tattooing
where like
on the outside it might look like this
but once you're in it you're like okay
this is like a little bit different that
people might expect I think I think the
design aspect of like getting the design
to like flow with the body I think we
kind of have to do that today a little
bit yeah yeah yeah
because you know a lot of people don't
really take into account how like
muscles flow and how things might warp
and things like that yeah I mean so yeah
just getting the piece to flow with uh
with the body correctly yeah it's always
a tough part like making sure the art
matches the canvas type of thing exactly
well this one's coming up pretty cool
all right after almost 12 hours
we're done
but it looks sick wow look at that
dang
let me zoom in a little more
that is dope boom shakalaka d d let me
zoom in even more than that
that's dope
that's so cool
hell yeah
thanks dude yeah oh yeah man finally
driving home
it's been a long day I got there at like
10.
and now it's 12 midnight although we
didn't start until around noon because
we're trying to get that design right
God damn they weren't lying when they
said that the inner bicep is painful a
lot of people told me at the inner bicep
and like the ribs are one of the most
painful places
um I never got any tattoos on the ribs
but my bicep was the place that was
empty and I like to keep like one side
of my body
untatted so I know what it always looks
like the way I was born and I want a
tattoo only one side at a time you know
so I was like oh I got this cool idea
let's fill in that bicep that bicep is
has space on my left arm and boy oh boy
I would say starting in like the first
10 minutes I was like I think I'm gonna
need to quit or something because this
is [__] painful
but we pushed through
finally done
finally going home
um pretty sure Geo and taika
are sleeping so I won't be able to show
them
so maybe I'll show them in the morning
my CUNY mama who waited up because she
knows how excited I am to show her the
tattoo
you big CUNY I'm just okay so I uh I'm
just like portraits for me it's
something that I probably wouldn't get
it's hard for me to want to get it yeah
just because like any like crook like
any like bad Shadow or or like
yeah it'll just distort the image of
that person that I wanted on my body
forever so I get so scared yeah
so I'm just like I hope you love it I
hope you love it I do love it you do
yeah because one of my favorite moments
is Cutie Pie of course the moment is
fine yeah the person execute
I hope so what are you talking about do
you like it yeah you wanna take a look
of course can you you could you could
you want to get YouTube with it
Okay so
[Music]
oh [__] how are you gonna put it back on
oh she can even see
no huh no
damn it yeah cause I'm like
anti-climactic yeah because I feel like
yeah I can't see [__] I guess I could
try to take it off and then put it back
on
see how did it even wrap it okay just
wait just wait when are you supposed to
take it off tomorrow morning oh I'll
wait tomorrow morning I have a good
picture of it though yeah we look jacked
dude yeah you look good oh thank you
yeah I got I took a good picture of it
though
switch switch
how about that hold on your phone turned
off
[Music]
okay here we go this one yeah that one
a picture okay wait can I just look at
that yeah
if you have a little Krabby crabs I love
him yeah
oh yeah misses you
oh [__] that's really good that's him
right there that's so cute little cutie
guy that's cutie huh
I want one I want the same one
so [__] cute it was his boobs
you have the dumbest collection I swear
to God I do me too
YOLO look at that this is CUNY love
hoodies everyone else at the shop was
like dude that's so freaking cool they
love they love the picture you're a
Visionary man thank you Mama and this
guy is just the perfect model
his life is this
that's him it looks like he's out of
aquarium and he's just swimming across
this way
like he's like a big killer whale and
he's just like going up hi everybody
laughs
monkey you want to see it yeah okay
stand right there
pretty CUNY
are you ready
what do you took your shirt off
that's the only way to take this off
look it got big wait is it right there
[Music]
you see it you have five tattoos yeah
three
four
okay one two oh and then five you're
right he likes to keep track of all the
stuff but look don't touch it okay
because it's brand new but look remember
those crab goggles
[Music]
how many do y'all have uh three
yes
one
two
three oh four four yeah you've got that
time I did but yours your papa got a
better one because he has your face on
his body forever
he can't take that off anymore
this is water show him the original
picture he may not know what the picture
is that was like 100 years old no
you don't do you remember the picture of
you in the pool when you when you were
diving I saw a picture of that me it's
not I mean that's a tattoo of the
picture
so Papa's gonna show you one second okay
shoot the camera
this is the picture
this one remember this one oh yeah let's
see
yeah but a kidney face and then look at
the crap the crab pickles
yeah oh yeah
pretty cool huh bye-bye goodbye
[Music]